Trascrizione: Tullio Tricarico Millefiori
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ho un po' rimodulato il mio discorso
partendo dal tema di questa serata,
che è quello della connessione
tra le persone, tra le società.
La mia storia è una storia di connessione:
sia quella culturale,
piuttosto che quella professionale.
Io vengo da un paese, il Camerun,
e ho scelto l'Italia
perché mi sono innamorato dell'Italia.
Partendo da cosa?
Partendo dai mondiali
di calcio, Italia '90.
Il mio paese, il Camerun,
venne a partecipare alla Coppa
del Mondo in questo paese:
e per me, e per noi camerunensi,
è stato qualcosa di grandioso,
visto quello che aveva fatto
la nostra nazionale di calcio.
A me interessava poco di calcio,
mi interessavano altre cose,
dell'Italia, di quei mondiali:
per esempio, la canzone
di Gianna Nannini e Edoardo Bennato,
"Notti magiche":
la cantavo ovunque.
Ero diventato - l'Italia
era diventata la mia seconda nazione.
Ero un tifoso di Totò Schillaci,
di Roberto Baggio.
E da lì è nato questo legame,
questa connessione
sentimentale con l'Italia:
ho deciso che da grande
volevo venire in Italia.
La maggior parte dei miei connazionali
vanno in Francia, vanno in Inghilterra,
perché il nostro paese, il Camerun,
è stato colonizzato da queste due nazioni;
ma io ho scelto l'Italia.
Una scelta incomprensibile
per la maggior parte dei miei amici,
dei miei familiari;
però era una scelta di cuore.
Ed è così che, nel 2008,
realizzo questo sogno:
arrivo in Italia per motivi di studio
al Politecnico di Torino,
dove mi sono laureato nel 2013.
Però succede qualcosa di importante,
e che ha cambiato la mia vita,
nel frattempo, mentre studiavo ancora,
ed è stato che nel 2011
perdo la borsa di studio al Politecnico.
E questo significava, per me,
pagare tasse più alte,
uscire dal sistema delle agevolazioni;
e quindi devo trovare un lavoro,
per la prima volta.
Mi metto alla ricerca di un lavoro.
Ed è così che, grazie al passaparola,
un amico mi parla
della raccolta dei pomodori
in Puglia, a Nardò, in provincia di Lecce.
Non conoscevo nulla della Puglia.
Ho fatto questa
"immigrazione all'inverso",
dal nord verso il sud.
E sono arrivato in Puglia,
sono arrivato a Nardò.
E ho scoperto il lato oscuro,
uno dei tanti lati oscuri di questo paese:
lo sfruttamento, il caporalato.
Fenomeni che non avevo mai subito,
non ne avevo mai sentito parlare
neanche nel mio paese, il Camerun.
Ho trovato un sistema che tendeva
a calpestare la dignità delle persone.
Io vengo da una terra, il Camerun;
e vengo da un continente, come l'Africa,
dove è vero, c'è povertà;
però, dentro quella povertà c'è dignità.
Qui, in quel momento,
ho scoperto un sistema
che ha la tendenza a calpestare
questa dignità, che per me era sacra.
Allora ho deciso
di organizzare lo sciopero,
ho conosciuto i caporali
che ci portavano tutti i giorni
a lavorare alle cinque di mattina,
e tornavamo intorno
alle sette, otto di sera.
Lavoravamo per circa 16 ore al giorno:
tutto il sistema
di pagamento era a cottimo,
eravamo costretti a riempire
delle casse di pomodoro.
Una cassa di pomodori,
ripiena di pomodoro,
pesava tre quintali, 300 kg;
e il caporale te la pagava €3,50
per 300 kg di pomodoro.
Per cui la tua paga giornaliera
era proporzionale al numero di cassoni
che tu riescivi a riempire
durante la giornata.
Io non superavo mai i quattro cassoni:
quindi avevo un guadagno massimo
di 14 euro al giorno.
Lordi, attenzione:
perché tutti questi soldi non andavano
a finire nelle mie tasche,
perché dovevamo pagare -
eravamo costretti, a pagare -
tutta una serie di servizi ai caporali:
il trasporto,
per portarci dalla baraccopoli,
dal ghetto dove vivevamo, verso i campi,
dovevo pagare cinque euro di trasporto;
dovevamo pagare l'acqua,
€1,50; il panino, €3,50.
Ogni giorno, un lavoratore
doveva mettere da parte minimo dieci euro
per pagare questi servizi;
quindi fare un numero di cassoni,
riempire un numero di cassoni
tale da superare questa soglia,
altrimenti lavoravi per 16 ore
senza tornare con nulla a casa.
Questo era il lavoro
dei braccianti, in quel momento.
Ed è quello che succede ancora, tutt'ora.
Non ce la facevo più,
ho deciso di organizzare questo sciopero:
eravamo circa 1000 persone,
originarie tutte dall'Africa,
in quell'area.
Attenzione: ci sono tanti altri lavoratori
di altri paesi, compresi gli italiani,
che vengono sfruttati
nelle nostre campagne.
Quello sciopero ha suscitato nel paese
una dinamica politica e sociale
che ha portato, come è stato ricordato,
alla legge sul caporalato.
Lo sfruttamento non riguarda
soltanto le campagne di Nardò,
non riguarda soltanto la Puglia:
riguarda e investe tutto il paese.
Questi lavoratori si spostano
da una regione all'altra,
a seconda della stagionalità
delle colture.
D'estate sono in Puglia,
in provincia di Foggia:
in particolare, i 50.000 ragazzi
che vengono sfruttati dai caporali
poi si spostano in Calabria,
perché lì d'inverno maturano
la raccolta degli agrumi;
poi scendono in Sicilia, a Cassibile,
piuttosto che a Campobello di Mazara,
girano per tutto il paese in campagna.
Anche nel nord Italia:
nella Franciacorta; le mele del Triestino,
piuttosto che il mais mantovano
che ci consente di fare la polenta;
nella zona del Chianti,
nella raccolta dei famosi vini,
cioè per produrre il vino,
i famosi vini toscani,
purtroppo, vengono prodotti
grazie allo sfruttamento
di questa manodopera.
Questo è il quadro
della situazione nel nostro paese.
Allora io, dopo lo sciopero
ho deciso di impegnarmi:
sono tornato a finire
gli studi, mi sono laureato.
Però è stato qualcosa di forte
che ha cambiato la mia vita,
ho deciso di impegnarmi
nel contrastare questo fenomeno.
Ed è così che ho girato l'Italia,
e alla fine ho deciso
di creare questa associazione,
perché ho capito -
avendo anche questa
formazione ingegneristica,
mi sono posto delle domande:
ma se ci sono i caporali,
chi sono i generali?
Sicuramente ci sono i generali.
Ho capito che lo sfruttamento
è funzionale a un sistema economico,
che i veri responsabili
del caporalato e dello sfruttamento
si nascondono nelle nostre città.
Non nelle campagne, come fanno
i caporali con i lavoratori.
Sono queste multinazionali,
sono la grande distribuzione organizzata,
i supermercati.
Sono loro le vere cause
dello sfruttamento in agricoltura.
Perché?
Perché sono loro che impongono
i prezzi dei prodotti:
se i prezzi sono bassi,
è chiaro che il produttore,
il contadino foggiano,
il contadino campano
non ce la farà mai a sostenere
determinati costi,
tra cui anche il costo del lavoro.
Tre anni fa abbiamo assistito
alla rivolta dei pastori sardi,
che buttavano il latte
perché non conveniva produrre il latte
a sessanta centesimi al litro:
è la stessa cosa
che succede in agricoltura.
I prezzi vengono imposti
dai supermercati, non dai produttori:
una cosa illogica,
perché la logica vorrebbe
che chi determina il prezzo
è quello che produce,
è l'agricoltore che sa quanto ha speso
per produrre quel prodotto.
Ma nel sistema attuale,
ultraliberista, non è così:
è chi compra, il supermercato,
che indica al produttore
il prezzo al quale
dovrebbe vendere la sua merce.
E nessuno ne parla:
è più facile parlare dei caporali.
È più facile, diciamo,
avere un approccio repressivo
verso gli agricoltori
e lasciare invece chi, in realtà,
produce questo sistema.
Per cui la mia associazione, "No Cap",
che sta per "No caporalato",
ha deciso di andare ad aggredire,
a colpire le cause reali
di questo fenomeno.
E ha messo in campo, quindi,
questo bollino, il bollino "No Cap",
perché abbiamo capito che bisogna
intervenire non solo sulla repressione.
È vero, la legge sul caporalato
l'abbiamo anche grazie a quelle rivolte:
finalmente l'Italia, questo paese,
si è dotato di uno strumento importante.
Però bisogna lavorare sulla prevenzione,
e prevenzione per noi significa
andare a intervenire sulle filiere.
Per cui abbiamo deciso di mettere insieme
le tre sostenibilità
di cui Andrea parlava prima:
la sostenibilità sociale,
insieme a quella ambientale,
e soprattutto assieme a quella economica,
perché se il prodotto costa poco
è chiaro che l'agricoltore
non ce la farà mai.
Però, c'è un altro aspetto importante
in questa battaglia:
l'agricoltura e la filiera produttiva
sono come una piramide,
dove alla base ci sono i braccianti;
poi abbiamo altri attori importanti,
produttori, la distribuzione;
ma c'è un altro segmento,
attore importante di questa filiera,
che sono i cittadini consumatori.
Per cui, mi vorrei rivolgere
a ciascuno di voi.
Noi ogni giorno mangiamo:
sono 60 milioni di italiani
che mangiano tutti i giorni.
E io faccio sempre un appello
alla vostra coscienza critica:
ogni volta che noi andiamo a comprare
un prodotto in quei supermercati -
che io chiamo i generali,
perché se ci sono i caporali
loro sono i generali.
Ogni volta che andiamo a fare la spesa,
dobbiamo porci delle domande:
ma quel pomodoro che sto
per comprare, da dove viene?
Chi l'ha raccolto?
Come è stato raccolto?
Queste domande cambieranno il mondo,
cambieranno la vita di quel bracciante
e di quel produttore.
Questa è la sfida, oggi,
che noi abbiamo lanciato:
suscitare una coscienza critica,
portare il consumatore
a una certa consapevolezza
di ciò che consuma.
Perché tutti questi fenomeni
che vi ho descritto
si basano sulla
massimizzazione del profitto,
hanno come unica componente
quella economica.
Per cui il consumatore ha questo potere:
quei 25 miliardi, stimati,
che sono il fatturato delle agromafie,
del caporalato, delllo sfruttamento,
provengono dalle tasche dei cittadini.
Per cui, una scelta consapevole oggi
farà la differenza domani.
Non possiamo più permettere
che oggi ci sia un sistema agricolo
che è basato tutto sul mercato,
e dimentichiamo la cosa
più importante: i diritti.
Oggi abbiamo un sistema
per il quale il prodotto
vale più dell'essere umano:
non è più possibile.
Per cui faccio un appello
a ciascuno di noi:
iniziamo questa rivoluzione.
Queste battaglie sembrano lontane da noi.
Abbiamo parlato di connessione:
il cibo va a finire sulle nostre tavole,
e tre prodotti su cinque che consumiamo
derivano dallo sfruttamento.
Quindi dobbiamo connetterci
tra tutti gli attori:
una grande alleanza,
tra i braccianti, contadini,
produttori e consumatori consapevoli
cambierà questo sistema.
(Applausi)